I'm Danica Patrick and I'm pretty
intense please clarify although I'm
generally going on but if you took and
condensed all of the atoms down to
actual matter yes like all the people on
earth it's the size of an apple or
something like yeah yeah so it's kind of
blows my mind okay let me let me
complete the mind-blowing
please dimension of this okay there's a
guy named first Rutherford he was a New
Zealand physicist and he wondered how
much stuff is in a net there's a nucleus
an electron so he took gold and hammered
it very thin gold has this you this
unique property that you can hammer it's
so thin it's almost just a few atoms
thick across that so that's why this
gold flower on there in ancient times
because they can stay together not only
hands together but you can you can form
it you can form it and you don't have to
use very much of it okay and you can
cover things and the whole thing's very
shiny gold you've used real gold okay so
that you can make it Sophia it's not
that expensive okay so that's why gold
is good for it's usually made what's
holds like for I'm gold plating came
from exactly exactly exactly so you made
a gold foil and just sort of dangled it
there and then he fired particles mm-hmm
into this go forth and he wanted to see
how many of them would get stopped or
ricocheted off her will pass through he
expected most to be just ricocheted off
this is you can't see through the gold
foil right it is solid as far as your
concern right and 99.99% of all
particles went through as though nothing
was there god I love science okay well
I'm not even done yet laughs and he he
freaked out what's going on here maybe
did the particle go in and then get
stopped and then a step another one come
out maybe it's just a transfer thing
no it
was mostly empty and he concluded that
the space between the nucleus of an atom
and the electrons is this vast chasm of
nothingness and it is rumoured that the
next morning when he woke up he alone
knew how empty matter was he was afraid
to step onto the floor sure to be up in
high-rise standing on earth lest he fall
through the atoms down to the basement
because science once you know you know
you can't know can't uh no you can't
unknow so now if you want to compress
everything if you want to compress yeah
all the people in the world can press us
down and and fill in all those gaps yeah
yeah I have to do the calculation but
Apple said maybe a maybe a plum yeah we
all just fit into that little ball of
the human race would fit into that
volume so what the hell are we what are
we well I so I think you're over valuing
the the matter part yet matter matters
but the space you occupy includes space
nothing wrong with that so we're just
Stardust
we've always been Stardust
[Music]